i'm so curious about this
what do you think fans of jackass would
be surprised to learn about the actual
making of a jackass movie hmm surprise
it's not easy
um
it hurts
um
there really is a camaraderie not just
onset but also offset we really do enjoy
hanging out with each other and spending
time together i don't know if that's a
surprise but um sometimes people might
wonder if if they are friends really
offset and they are and
yeah it was really cool to spend time
with them
nice guys yeah that's our family now
yeah i think people would be surprised
to know they really are nice guys and
love and loving
is there because it seems to me like
jeff is willing to film anything on set
and put all of you guys through the
ringer so is there like a safe word that
you each have that like lets jeff know
this is just too far
i didn't know we could use safe words
the safe word is when you're knocked out
and you can't talk
nowhere is the safe word
[Laughter]
does anyone on set actually um like
trade a stun when you know like when you
not stuff when it's like the lights are
out and you don't know what's coming but
like when there is a different kind of
stunt does someone ever like say i i
cannot do this and someone else is like
i'll do this
uh i mean like sometimes like if someone
was like injured or something and then
it's like oh they literally can't do it
then like someone else will do it
sometimes or like the way to that person
heals or whatever it just depends we'll
do anything i've seen that happen before
nobody really said no to like what they
had to do you don't want to say no as a
new cast member you know you look like
yeah
i i said that i would i wouldn't say no
to anything like when i started when i
was like starting the movie and i didn't
so
yeah they didn't put us through the
bowls though that's one thing i would
have been like really thinking about
like
am i going to break my femur you know so
after knoxville did the bull stuff kind
of the mood kind of just like was
was really like wow so
but we're really lucky we didn't have to
get in that ring
yeah
a hundred percent um have you guys
actually spoken to jeff
about
uh
continuing jackass like jackass the new
generation or anything along those lines
no we don't really ask them too many
questions you know that's that's their
deal we're hoping they'll come to us and
tell us yeah i'm gonna text him about it
later but we're ready we're ready for
sure yeah we're gonna ask him about it
now actually yeah yeah we're gonna ask
him after this usually say every movie
is their last movie and they're on
number four now so you never know what
might happen yeah listen also the title
jackass the new generation i'm you know
it's better than geriatric jackass
exactly
so obviously spike jones is involved in
this and the thing that i find about
spike is that no matter when he's on
camera no one goes after him so is there
like a rule on set that no one can [ __ ]
with you know spike on set
i don't know i would be too scared yeah
you don't really want to mess with him
because um he's like
he's valuable
yeah he can like make things happen to
you that you don't ever want to happen
but jeff jermaine we come after him yeah
literally you gotta get him
this is probably gonna be my last
question i'm just about out of time but
what was
the most scared you were on set whether
like for whatever it may be it could
have been something else that someone
else was doing uh but i'm just curious
like what was the day that you're like
oh
f
yeah for me it was just the bull thing i
don't like when we saw johnny get
ran by the boy it was not
cool to see yeah i was definitely
intimidated by the scorpion that day i
was nervous because i've i've never
really interacted with uh insect like
that before
i'm just going to say again uh
congratulations on the movie i want to
thank you for making me
laugh at your pain i'm sorry about that
and uh welcome
right
have a fantastic afternoon thank you so
much
you